[Music]
i genuinely wish that i like heard
that question more with people like with
like a i wish i heard that question more
like knowing that people's intentions
were to hear how i actually was doing
i'm fine but not like the best to be
honest
um i like drank a whole bot a whole
bunch with my family last night and i
don't remember what i did or said so
like i'm kind of like feeling like
regret about that
and so like that's just like an
immediate thing that's making me feel a
little bit wonky
but like overall like i'm i'm
i'm all right just lately with
school and work stress a lot of days i
just want to go home lay on my floor and
scream
so that is that is how i am doing yeah
just a lot of pressure
i'm okay uh
all right i'm gonna answer this for real
um
i don't know life is hard i dropped out
of college
and i work two jobs that are really
really cool
but they don't pay a lot and so the
reality of like probably not moving out
for a really long time
is kind of on my shoulders now because
like my parents are going to move out of
the house and they're
kind of like where are you going to go
um
so i kind of wake up and think about
that every morning like do i give up
these jobs that i love and get like
a job that pays is there even a job that
pays for someone that dropped out of
college and
so i just don't know where i'm gonna go
i don't really get
asked that often to truthfully say how i
feel we were chugging along
kind of like um wadding through water
that's probably
up to you like shin level where it's not
slowing you down
but it's kind of still hard to move
i'm about to graduate and i don't know
the world feels really
big like there's so many alternative
knees that could be spread out from this
point like a me that maybe goes to grad
school or uh
or me that goes to tokyo or me that
stays in san diego and
it's kind of hard to choose which you
you want to pursue
but at the current moment right now i'm
having a really great time hanging out
with my friend
we saw some baby ducks that are now like
grown
you know they're getting on this life so
you know i guess i should be able to
go and get on with life good i'm just
having a nice day and i woke up feeling
nice
and good i'm really happy
why do you say that uh because i met
somebody that
feels like home so how does home feel
uh safe
love
[Music]
me
the true answer would be
not so well i am like am i supposed to
get like a real like
in-depth like is that what you want um
i suffer from like mental illness and
stuff like that
and um i've been good for a while i've
been in hospitals before and stuff like
that but i've been good for a while
but lately i just kind of felt like numb
like i'm not getting better but i'm not
getting worse kind of
kind of just kind of stuck in the same
place
and i don't know it doesn't feel good if
i don't think about it too much i'm not
getting worse but then it's like i'm not
getting better then i'm getting worse
you know with my with my own struggles
but
but yeah that's basically it today i am
blessed i um actually have a year in two
months sober
so my life today when you say how are
you doing
i can actually really say genuinely from
my heart
i am doing great i am doing amazing
um my god is my higher power and my lord
and uh
today i'm just i'm so blessed to have my
family back in my life
and um i woke up sober today so i'm
doing great
i'm scared that i'm gonna just work
like a nine to five the rest of my life
and not do anything i want
so i'm currently happy but i want to
figure out how to
[Music]
set myself up long term to be happy
i'm in a rehab program and it sucks
but i'm almost out of there
i'm fine on depression meds i'm
a heroin addict but i'm doing okay so
what led you to make the change my
children
probably like a 4.5 out of 10.
why do you say that because i'm probably
worried about paying half my rent before
the weekends
you know what i'm really insecure
i'm doing well but i'm really insecure
and that's just how it is and i'm hoping
to work through that and to be
to feel strong and feel vibrant but yeah
knee-jerk reaction
insecure honestly i'm confused
i'm 20 years old i live in the most
expensive city in the world
i don't know what i'm doing i don't know
if like i'm studying the right thing
because it's so
white and i don't know if i'm going to
actually make a difference
so i'm kind of just like in a really
weird headspace of what the heck am i
doing
you know i don't know when i'm where i'm
gonna live next semester
um i don't know if i'm gonna be able to
afford it
um i don't know if i'm getting financial
aid because i'm struggling academically
um what else i'm lonely
but it's okay because i have really
great friends um
i like being alive but um i'm confused
i'm really confused
i want to say fine but i'm doing good
now
and in a way
definitely better than like two years
ago okay well i was how are you feeling
two years ago
depressed and not in a good place
very i was going to uh
maybe i shouldn't really admit it though
but let's just say i probably wouldn't
have been alive by now
and yeah
that i don't know what changed
uh i told my dad how i was feeling and
then like he just said let's go for a
walk and i'm
like okay i'll just go for a walk and
then
we just like talked about it and i think
and stuff like that i'm like well i
guess i need to like start
doing things like well if i die then i
guess i'll have to
well who's gonna take care of my birds
and who's gonna
keep drawing my art and i have to do
that
so i think i'm okay
i think i'm okay i think i've been
better and i've been worse
i think today i'm having a day of like
self-reflection
so worse would probably be i'd say a few
years ago i was in a really terrible
relationship
i think i didn't really know who i was i
didn't really want to be alone
um i think the last few years after that
i've
been okay with being alone i would never
even just be sat here by myself
like that's weird i would never never
think of doing that
so even that in itself was when i was
worse probably
i think better is just any time after
that so
i feel like there's still some way for
me to go but
i'm not there yet i'm doing
okay right now because
i care deeply about someone for once
it is returned into the same amount
and so it makes me really happy and gets
me through most of my days
and so that's why i'm okay right now i
battled through uh
many struggles in life many trials and
tribulations
whether it's uh gangs violence drugs
but now where i stand i i'm truly
blessed where i'm at
i i completely changed my life a
complete 360 and
and that's who i am right now like i
didn't do it for anybody else but me
because i've been through a lot but i
know that that's not going to lead me to
anywhere good
[Music]
how am i doing i think i'm doing better
than i thought
sometimes you don't still give yourself
credit for what you have accomplished
really
terrible
[Music]
why is that um
i don't know i just have a lot going on
i am doing very well today's just been a
great day
um i became a college graduate today at
the end of my graduation
just been enjoying a vacation with my
wife daughter and family so
i feel like a million dollars today i
really do
i'm actually pretty cold right now
um but overall i guess
always good trying to be good you know
i i'm
i'm hungry what i ate for lunch doesn't
really agree with me so it's sort of
hurting my insides a little bit
so you know i'm starting to feel that
but then i'm also feeling a little bit
hungry now because it's almost dinner
time so it's weird because
you know i just sort of have this
internal pain of
hungry and then pain from lunch i don't
know
how to explain that but it's weird
but other than that i'm looking forward
to sleeping tonight
struggling why is that there's a lot of
underlying
things that people don't talk about you
go how are you and the
very subjective answers to say good or
i'm doing well but no one really gets to
the bottom of it
and say oh yeah i'm doing because my dog
did on the couch today no one says that
so there's a lot of things that people
don't talk about you just have to be
normal
so what are you struggling with right
now a lot of anxiety
i'm slightly loopy i feel kind of warm
i'm a little bit chilly i
didn't sleep enough last night i
am trying really hard to answer this
honestly i
am um is there a time limit
how am i doing
i guess how are you doing and
it implies that there's like a shift
right
or that like you had known from some
point how i was doing
i don't know how do you feel
because it's really what's really hard
to describe without going into
everything that you don't already know
about my life which is kind of what i
was saying about it being like a weird
shift
it's like how am i doing is relative to
like everything that's happened
for the past always
because yeah i feel like there is no how
i'm doing
so what if i said can you like generally
give us tell us who you are
and then tell us how you're doing based
on that
[Music]
i'm really bad at this no you're doing
great well i'm not from here obviously
i'm from atlanta i think
me being here is
i think it puts me in a space where i am
like really fleeting
kind of and i maybe that's why it's so
hard to answer it's because i'm
in like an unfamiliar space and i'm just
like
i feel like every moment is like a new
how i'm doing
rather than it's not my normal day by
day
hey everyone to end this episode i
thought i'd talk about something that's
been on my mind
lately i feel like i don't do enough for
those of you who reach out to me in the
comments
and share your stories and struggles
with mental illness
so i thought it would be cool to make
this episode and in honor of mental
health awareness month
i'm dedicating it to all of you who've
been brave enough to share your stories
with me
and anyone else who deals with mental
illness that's pretty much it
thank you guys for watching and i'll see
you next week
you